welcome to a fresh take on the news
putting you at the center of the
national conversation about the issues
that matter to you most
tonight the spending squeeze bites as
house prices reach a record high
there's a warning the worst is yet to
come for food prices
energy bills are rocketing and tax
increases are on the way
i'm trevor phillips and this is the
great debate
[Applause]
each week we get to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines
tonight with a prime minister battling
to stay in his job and the cost of
living soaring
our viewers panel from across the
country will tell their stories they'll
have their say
and hold our studio guests to account
and with us tonight
bill bullon founder and ceo of utilita
energy
comedian and anti-poverty campaigner
lucy beaumont
the entrepreneur and businessman piers
linney
and former conservative mp and economic
secretary to the treasury justine
greening
and the big question facing us all
tonight
broke britain
can you afford the cost of living crisis
everything seems to be going up and it's
not going up one or two pence it's going
up 20 pence 50 pence
i would sooner have the heating on then
i would have something to eat
a weekly shop for our groceries is
increasing between 15 and 25
for me to stand here and pretend we
don't have to adjust to paying higher
prices
would be wrong and dishonest
the national insurance rise to help pay
for the nhs and social care is on the
way
it just feels like it's always the
people that are worse off
that are hit in the pocket
families in britain will be still paying
hundreds of pounds more for their energy
what can we do about it
nothing
as always we'll start with our viewers
panel so let's go to the wall
mark hill in sirencester
can you tell us your experience
yeah um i'm married my wife's disabled
i've worked at the same job for 22 years
my hip went back in july 2020 so i can't
work at the moment
um i had to deal with it not being able
to go to work not being able to walk
properly being in pain
um
locked down
rising bills and no depression
i went on to universal credit when my
sick pay ran out the first time i've
ever done it
the first thing that happened was i had
a 80 pound taken away from me um which
was a surprise
i've used up all my savings just to get
through paying the bills um until i
could get used to what i'm doing
i've cancelled a lot of subscriptions uh
i've even cancelled a couple of payments
that i used to do to charities because i
can't afford it
i've sold a lot of the things that
i've built up over the years i've sold
just to get money in um
unfortunately my gas supplier an
electric supplier was one of the ones
that went into administration so my
bills have gone from 60 to 160 pounds
we don't put the heating on at all we
keep the heating off we use the washing
machine once a week
we keep the lights off as much as
possible um
to try and save electric and money it's
the gas that's the biggest problem the
gas is higher because we've got a gas
cooker as well so the gas is costing us
more
i'm not so much worried about yourself
although i'm suffering from depression
because of it i'm worried about my
family and where we're going to be in
the future
mark thank you for sharing that with us
let's go to
celia hensman
celia
do you want to tell us your experience
well i'm also have a disability um
and my my greatest concern with the cost
of living is on average it's about
583 pounds extra a month it costs to
have a disability so that covers costs
of additional heating prescriptions
whether you need to take extra public
transport to get your appointments
one in five people who have a disability
pay over a thousand pounds extra a month
than the average person because of their
disability
what is this additional cost to living
going to do to disabled people and what
can we do to protect them when they are
already paying much higher cost to live
in society than the average person
let's go to fife where mark bennett has
a question for our panel
mark
all right thank you very much yes i do
have a question that it's a it's a quite
simple one um
with everyone's uh bills that are going
up um in all sorts of ways and
everything how comes how comes the
government seems to want to just blanket
everybody and tarnish you know give
everybody exactly the same
when there are clearly people like
myself
who
are in a very fortunate position that
that extra money that they're going to
give me for the bills for for the
electricity and the heating
i don't actually i don't actually need
it uh i don't personally need it i would
rather it go to
someone like the other mark
who needs the money you know i'm i'm
okay i live in an affluent uh village i
live in an affluent place
um i've got money you know i've i've
worked all my life i'm now retired i'll
sit on my backside and do bugger all
right um but you know surely someone
okay
you know as lucy would say someone else
and john's grove in whole they would
need a hell of a lot more money than i
would need okay mark thank you very much
for that really interesting point which
has got some support from our wall so
panel the question there from mark is
why isn't the government giving targeted
support to those who need it the most
instead of blanket handout
justin greening when you're in
government this might have been a
question for you
yeah and i'm not obviously not in
government now i think
the challenge is getting that balance
right especially when the cost of living
rises are affecting everyone and i think
that was one of the concerns
that people have that actually a lot of
families not just those at the
if you like facing the most challenges
already this is now catching the
mainstream of many many people who are
facing a challenge of maybe several
hundreds probably a thousand plus pounds
plus tax rises so i think it is hard to
get that balance right my sense is
actually there does need to be more
targeting and i think one of the
challenges the government's got itself
into
is that a lot of these changes have been
late in the day so they've been overlaid
one on the other one on the other one on
the other so you've ended up now with
things pulling in different directions
some
measures the government wants to take
that are meant to be targeted and it's
trying to do that directly through
energy bills it's trying to do it
directly through councils but that's not
always working effectively then
setting aside that were plans already in
place to raise taxes
i think what it now needs to do is
probably step back and decide how it
wants to simplify that because i think a
lot of people don't actually know
necessarily
what support is there for them or where
to get it and it's complicated okay
there's some support there from justine
for the idea of targeting and there's
some uh support uh from our wall here
pierce lenny what do you think do you
agree that
the current measures are maybe
too uniform
so in the ideal world you get the exact
right amount of money to the right
person the thing about government and
having been involved in government and
distributing funds out to businesses
across the uk is that they need
mechanisms that can work very very
quickly so what they tend to do is use
the systems are already there because
implementing new ones would take too
long but i think the problem is is that
we're always talking about the average
person in the average situation on the
average earnings in the average place
most people are going to suffer on the
average person it's the edge cases the
people that mark was talking about so
we've got to find ways of targeting and
directing resources we've got more
accurately at those people which is not
easy to do but we need some more
thoughts about how we do that
lucy beaumont um we know you as a
comedian but also you're an anti-poverty
campaigner what do you make of this
idea that we should target measures more
for me and and the the the charity work
that i've done in in the last few years
um
for the people that need it the most
there isn't time to talk
there isn't time to think these are this
isn't something that this this is a this
needed to be a lifeline this needed to
be an emergency package in the way it
was emergency package when we bailed out
big business
this is an emergency package we're not
of course there's going to be middle
income that might struggle you know they
might keep the hot tub off
do you know you know you might they
might go to aldi and not waitress
but what i think a lot of people i'm
sure a lot of people are worried about
what's keeping me awake at night
is is the families where this this is
this is this is the choice between a
mother feeding the kids and thinking i
can't feed the kids i'm gonna have to go
on the game tonight
this is them saying i have to stay with
my abusive partner because i can't
afford to move this this is saying i
live with a disabled child and i can't
afford to keep the heating on and he
needs the heating on this is a lifeline
i'm i'm i'm devastated i'm so angry
at this stage i really am
but lucy the government does say that
they are
having a lifeline they are handing out
loans for uh council tax they are doing
something on the energy
150 quid because they never got to the
root problem because because austerity
was so harmful they are so far away what
they do not understand is you're talking
about families that have multiple
problems it's so complicated
the the way to get and it's not that the
thing is local councils know how to help
their communities they don't have the
resources and the funding to do it it
all comes down to not having enough
money to do the things all right let's
come back to the wall i want to talk to
rose malenga
buckle i've started questioning myself
who am i working for
because if i can't afford trevor
to have hitting in my house food is
expensive
petrol is expensive and we are talking
about national insurance being increased
what am i living for who am i working
for
am i a government machine to make money
for the government
without warming my house
i mean i'm from africa myself i cannot
afford trevor
to have no heating so my question to the
panel is who are we working for and what
is the purpose of me living in england
if i can't fit myself
billboarding
that's pretty heartfelt yeah who is she
working for
that's a tough question i mean you know
on this question of
energy price rises i mean obviously that
does hit everybody um
but as piers was saying you know we
don't have such a thing as an average
consumer and it's low-income households
who are already struggling have been
struggling this year and for example i
think over this just this winter that's
just gone we've been helping something
like 2 000 customers every day
on with some kind of financial
assistance so they're struggling now
we're going to put energy prices up
obviously we've also heard about food
prices and other basic commodities going
up i don't know what the effective
inflation rate is for low-income
households but it's it's way more than
seven and a half percent well you're
looking at 13 uh the the lowest deficit
that the lowest 10 income 10 of the
country spends 13
of their
income on energy compared to 4 at the
top so their inflation rate
is driven pretty strongly i mean what
she's saying is that she feels like
frankly she's working for you not for
her
i wouldn't say that she's working for me
because i think
as everybody knows energy companies
aren't making money at the moment with
the price capping regime that we've had
in place most energy companies have been
losing money for several years now
that's certainly the case for us so
i do sympathize
i also feel like we spend most of our
time working for the government as well
so
justine um
you heard what rose had to say and
there's a lot of support there on on the
wall for her sentiment
that actually all of this is working for
somebody else who's making a lot of
money somewhere else while she's paying
out
yeah and i think it's why you come back
to this fundamental discussion about how
we want to target support um
certainly when i was growing up my
family was one of those that was in that
situation of like trying to work out how
much time we could have our heating on
versus the rest of our bills my mom and
dad had to add up what they were going
to go to buy at the supermarket before
they left the house
to make sure they had the money to be
able to do that because it would have
been embarrassing they put more in their
basket than they could afford so
i think it is really hard and it
fundamentally comes down to a question
of how much do we want to tax working
people
and what do we want to do with the
benefits system and where are the lines
that we're drawing in our society about
being able to live
with dignity and getting that balance
right i want to come back to the we'll
talk about national insurance and all of
that in a moment before we do that i
want to talk to
joshua thompson smith i've um
an in professional engineer i graduated
um five years ago and i've been in
professional work for that period and i
live in an area that um is kind of a
tale of two halves you've got
a lot of people with disposable income
and that disposable income feeds local
business local pubs local cafes you've
also got
the town of burning up on trent where
it's going to be profoundly impacted and
it's the difference between heating your
home
or having a hot meal and for me that's
pretty hard to see as a young voter
someone that's voted in three general
elections um i don't see it as
acceptable personally
and when you look at this country
and you think about what we're doing
fiscal policy wise
why are we not looking towards the big
corporations
why are we not looking towards the
higher earners
why are we going for national insurance
rises squeezing the unearners the
younger earners through
student loan threshold freezing
why are we looking at
not trying to cap energy even more
and for me it brings me to the question
of is this government more interested in
actually protecting the voters for the
next general election such as the grey
pound you know that the voters are more
liquid cash are they more interested in
partying in number 10 because as a young
voter that's what i see um or are they
actually interested in leading this
great nation and these great people who
are on this panel and in this audience
through the next crisis joshua thank you
um piers linning
politics is politics getting in the way
and getting into a situation where
essentially what josh is talking about
the slogan people use these days as
heating or eating
so i think joshua made an important
point there that it is a great nation
and we're supposed to be this you know
whether you're for brexit or not i
wasn't particularly especially this
great nation which we are we've
fantastic opportunity but the issue is
is the politics typically is looking at
the next election which isn't even five
years away now so making decisions in
that time frame given where we are
doesn't really work we need to look
beyond it and we need to turn this
around and really stop talking about you
know talk about the issues but how do we
solve it how do we get out of it my view
it's all about growth and it's taking
people like joshua you know put the
hours in they're educated want to get
into the economy and actually making a
difference and creating some wealth and
some value because you've either got to
increase incomes or reduce costs we
can't do both well okay we're going to
get to that point eventually but
there's another part of this equation
prices are going up but incomes are
going down coming up next tax hikes on
the way
but how much extra will you have to pay
the planned rise to national insurance
will go ahead in april according to the
government it's not what anybody wants
to do so what richie wants to do it's
not what i want to do but we've got to
do it it's needed it really is needed
for the industry the wrong tax at the
wrong time it's not just the employees
that are going to have to pay more we're
going to have to make a larger
contribution as well
[Applause]
[Music]
which has always been at sandring
obviously last year because of the
pandemic last year sort of talking about
january she wasn't there because of
lockdown but it's always reflective uh
we've got to remember that 70 years ago
that she came to the throne incidentally
70 years ago today she arrived back in
the uk from uh
from kenya and i remember the death very
well i'm of that age
i was 11 years old when uh the news came
we were sent home from school uh when
there was no internet there were no
mobiles there were no email and news was
got by word of mouth or on the radio and
we had three uh uh evening papers the
first coming out at lunchtime and others
later in the day so it was the lunchtime
papers that broke the news and people
were actually tearful
and
it it it was the sign of the times but
for the queen it is reflected you've got
to remember too that this is the first
year with our prince phillip
so
it's a double reflection for her her
mentor her father and her strengths day
her husband of 73 years
we've seen it on previous jubilees on
the golden o2
77 the silver and who can forget the the
plat the diamond in 2012 with that
appearance on the balcony with very few
royals prince of wales duchess of
cornwall uh duke and duchess of
cambridge and prince harry unmarried at
the time so yes she is looking forward
to it and i hope that
her private staff secretary will
organize her her time between now and
then very very carefully maybe one or
two again engagements she's one of these
people that's always said i have to be
seen to be believed and she wants to be
seen not on television not on
on virtual but she wants to be seen in
person and i hope we are going to see
her between now and the big celebration
in june which is four days and i think
everybody's looking forward to it and
everybody's beginning to prepare for it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're talking about broke britain and
asking
can you afford the cost of living crisis
what happens when tax increases hit in a
couple of months in april national
insurance will go up both for employers
and employees
meaning less take-home pay
and that could have a real impact on
small businesses
uh an example the one owned by amanda
coleman who is going to talk to us now
amanda how are you going to cope with
this rise
well it's going to be really difficult
because
um i started the business back in march
2020 and was never eligible for any kind
of aid or support right the way through
the pandemic i spent the well coming up
to two years um and this last year i've
just about started to to get to a really
good position i'm looking to growth but
actually i'm not going to now i'm now
potentially going to be in a position
where i'm just about making um making
making ends meet and and surviving um so
it's going to be a difficult time ahead
crikey you absolutely had really bad
luck with the timing on that um have you
got a question for our panel
i have it is how can small businesses
survive the national insurance increase
okay thank you very much amanda a
question for our panelists how can small
businesses
survive the national insurance rise
pearson you deal with a lot of small
businesses support some
what are you telling the people that you
invest in
well i invested in them but also i've
got a business to support small
businesses so fantastic that you started
the business joined the pandemic
these people forget is if you've got an
income of salary costs are going up so
your car you're being your disposable
income is being squeezed if you've got a
small business and your your costs are
going up your margins being squeezed you
pass it on to your customer that's
inflation but often you're probably just
being squeezed in the middle because you
can't pass on those price increases so
your income actually is also under
threat so you've got a pincer movement
you're in a worst case scenario if
you've got a salary you can lose your
job potentially but if you've got a
small business you're finding that cop
prices are going up your income's going
down and the only way you can really do
that is to you know i mean people say
this is you need to go through your
entire every line of management accounts
and work out how can i reduce it take it
out and the thing about the uk is we are
suffering uh well this is well
documented from a lack of productivity
what we need to do is become more
efficient and try and rinse out the
opportunity we can with resources we've
got which are dwindling well but what
what does something like amanda do i
mean i uh i don't imagine that there's
that much fat to cut in her business
well i was like you've got two options
in mind haven't you got one is to grow
one is to sort of you know i think 77 of
small businesses are in a sort of
they're in stasis really they're not
expecting to grow and 44 we did some
research about even your mental health
65
are concerned they're going to gravitate
business so you've either got to stay
where you are and try and keep your
powder dry you can grow which is what
everyone wants to do or you have to
reduce costs but the only way out of
this i'm sure we'll come back to this is
to try and survive and then grow
absolutely one of the things i want to
do is grow small businesses at the heart
of communities and without small
businesses you know you're taking
another ass thing away from people um so
it's yes it's something i want to do i
think the difficulty is i'm really just
looking at getting my head down to
survive um over the next 12 months
okay let's go to um robin gillingham um
robin in devon um robin uh you've been
with us before hello again uh i hope
christmas is good to you what uh
what advice would you be giving to
anybody who has to deal with this
at one quarter percent rise in national
insurance contributions
um yeah i mean business and employees
are all feeling the um pinch at the
moment um personally i don't think we
can just blame inflation on the
household and business finances uh yes
inflation is happening but if we look
deeper you can also see how our society
has changed uh for example the
subscription culture that never used to
be around 10 to 20 years ago they're
easy to sign up to with seven day free
trials and click the button
um but these soon add up and sometimes
it's not a um easy or even possible to
cancel
when you need them to robin just to be
absolutely clear though
you do think that we need to raise this
money for health and social care
do you or not
the the national insurance rise is
supposed to deliver 12 billion
quid a year for health and social care
do you think we need that money or don't
we
yes i do
justin greeting um
robin says
get rid of your subscriptions though not
sky subscriptions everybody
that we could do more ourselves i think
there'll be a lot of people going
through their house or finances working
out
where they can save money across the
board to be honest and and i think this
is the challenge in a way because if you
don't have that demand in the economy
then that has a knock-on impact on jobs
so that's the big risk as you get into
this downward spiral where there's less
money being spent and therefore there
are fewer jobs because there's fewer
jobs there's less money being spent and
so at some stage what i would like to
see is a much longer term plan from
ministers because there's a challenge
today but fundamentally the seeds of why
people are
suffering now is
10 20 years ago when you're coming
through the education system you're not
getting the education you want you're
not in a position to get some of those
higher skilled jobs and we have to at
some point tackle today but we've got to
break that cycle
that we've had forever in britain which
is where you start in life tends to
shape where you end up if you start
behind you finish behind and that's what
we've got to change
yeah i totally agree but there's also
been in the last few years some absolute
draconian measures that have been put in
by the government that haven't worked
and haven't saved money and my mind are
almost criminal the devastation of call
the benefit sanctions the bedroom tax
the shake-up of universal credit
you know the the even just the closures
of libraries like sometimes the only
lifeline people have got to get
information and get into that
this these are the reasons why some of
our most
most vulnerable communities that are in
problems we're not talking about all
this in the light lucy that that's an
incredibly popular view on on our wall
but uh and in fact we'll talk to our
government minister a little later in
the program but
but this is don't you think we ought to
we could be doing more ourselves as
robin gillingham was saying
i mean my particular interest is is in
working with the most vulnerable and
then working up because we haven't
really got a society unless we've we've
sorted that out first i just feel to be
in this mess now to be punishing people
like this when they've caused so many
problems
the the meager amount of money they're
offering is is is is like it's like
throwing bread to ducks well we'll test
that out in a moment because after the
break energy minister greg hands will be
joining us to talk expensive bills
green taxes and how the government's
planning to help with the cost of living
crisis
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you're watching the great debate where
this week we're talking broke britain
can you afford the cost of living crisis
and a big part of the pressures facing
many people is a rise in energy bills
set to go up nearly 700 pounds a year
from april
the government's announced a 200 pound
discount to try to help but is that
enough
well
let's ask the energy minister greg hans
who's with us and uh we're going to
start with a question from zubair khan
in birmingham zubair
you've got a question for our panel and
for our minister
thank you um good evening panel the
coastal living crisis is going to have a
disproportionate impact on the most
vulnerable and poorest people in our
society
my question to the enemy minister is
what more can be done to help people
with rusting energy crises
thank you very much to bear um so his
que jabez question is what can be done
to help people with rocketing
energy costs greg hans um
what will you tell zubair khan when you
see him on the doorstep
well what i say to zabare is this that
the issue of rising energy prices
and rising cost of living prices is very
much on the government's agenda that's
why
uh the chance of the extracurricular
announced nine billion pounds of support
last week we've got to recognize that
energy prices are rising
due to global situations uh what's going
on between russia and ukraine there's
other reasons why global energy prices
are going up britain is not
immune from those global price rises but
that's why we've announced 9 billion
pounds of support 450 pounds
for many households most households in
the country
overall
there's also support coming through like
the rise in the national living wage
there's changes in the universal credit
taper rate that will provide support for
people so actually there's a lot of
government support coming through right
whilst recognizing we can't be immune uh
from these global forces driving up
energy prices all right let me come back
to
the our studio stay there for a moment
bill bullon is that enough do you think
that's going to be
make a big difference to your more
vulnerable poorer customers i think the
short answer has to be no i'm afraid um
when we did give this feedback to the
government last week when we first heard
about these this package of measures
um first of all the 200 pounds is just a
loan um
we have customers that can't afford
their energy now we're about to put
their energy prices up so i really don't
see how they ever get to pay that money
back
and you know obviously everybody's
getting the 200 pounds as well so it's
it's just not targeted enough um you
know we think the government could have
come up with you know about the package
size of the package seems to be about
right but it's just not targeted enough
on low-income households who we said
earlier on are facing a really
disproportionate rise in their cost of
living and consequently we're going to
see some real hardship next winter we're
seeing real hardship now and next winter
it's going to be a lot worse it's going
to be worse millions more households
millions more households
greg hans um that is pretty bleak isn't
it
the boss of an energy company says
the
help you're giving
and nine million is a big number but for
the individual person they're only
seeing a few hundred quid and some of
that is alone it really doesn't cut it
well it's not all alone and the loan is
there to provide the assistance up front
when it's most needed obviously the
council tax rebate for those living in
properties
bans a to d so are the less expensive
properties throughout the country
that is a one-off that is a one-off
payment that won't be repaid
and that comes in as early as april so
some of the support is repayable some of
it
won't be repaid but all of it will be
paid this year when people are facing uh
the increase in bills particularly the
rises in energy bills as i say driven by
global forces
zubair khan in uh birmingham
what are you thinking
bill bullon says not enough greg hans
says it will make a difference what do
you what's your view
well i think i've got with the um
view that any fundamental shop is really
appreciated by the most vulnerable and
native people in our society
as it's already been mentioned the 200
pound is the alarm so somewhere down the
line where people have to pay that back
so i think there should be much more
targeted sport mechanism in place for
people to access
this blanket approach is not suitable in
my view
because there are people in
certainly in society will not need that
amount and that can be redirected to the
people who really really need it to help
them and to decide whether to heat or uh
heat their home or buy food
zubair khan thank you so much let's go
to another uh
member of our viewers panel patricia
harvey
you've heard the discussion here what do
you make of it
yes thank you thank you trevor um
i think we should actually scrap or even
delay
the green transition
this funding that's going into reaching
the should i say net zero by 2050 should
be diverted into helping people
afford the imminent rising costs
yes i know i'm probably killing polar
bears
but i like my comfort and i think we all
need to have a comfortable standard
level of living greg hans
polar bears over people
let's let's delay the net zero pledge
no i i completely disagree with that
actually
um i totally respect the question uh but
actually
we need to reduce our dependence on
fossil fuels
and the way to do that is by building
our renewable energy capacity we've had
big success in this country we're a
world leader in this space for example
we've got the world's largest installed
offshore wind capacity the amount of our
electricity that's been
uh uh coming from renewables has gone up
from seven percent of the energy mix to
43
it's a big success but it reduces our
dependence on these volatile imported
fossil fuels so we're less dependent on
the global gas price okay more dependent
on our domestic renewables all right
patricia harvey
uh
what do you um
think of what greg hans has to say look
to the future he says
yes look for the future but i'm talking
about now i'm talking about the current
climate now i'm talking about dependent
families
people that cannot afford with these
fossil fuels and these wonderful energy
that's coming i'm talking about now and
the families and the should i say
elderly people who are struggling now
we need help now
200 pounds is nowhere near
when the average fuel bill is 700 pounds
plus this year people just cannot afford
this they are there are struggling
families out there
okay thank you for tuning to lizzie yeah
i i would just like to know what is the
reason to give to support to people that
don't need it what what is the reason
why wow
you know
i work in tv why do i need 200 pounds i
don't i don't need it why why couldn't
why can't that be going to people that
do need it what is the reason
because even the even the amount that's
going to be given to local authorities
still isn't
enough i would really like to know what
is the reason you aren't giving more
support to the people that need it the
most greg happens this is an interesting
point
more but why not spend on the people who
most need it
well we are giving that support the
hundred and fifty pounds
her point is that the point that's being
made here is you're giving a lot of
money to a lot of people for to whom
it's not going to make much difference
well that's the repayable
okay first to note that is the repayable
part of the programs get repaid over
five years the amount of money that is
being given as a rebate the council tax
rebate for example goes to those in
bands a to d properties i.e the less
expensive properties we also have the
existing schemes the warm homes discount
which is a levy on better off fuel
payers and that warm homes discount now
going to a hundred and fifty pounds is
going to less well well-off uh bill
payer so there already is quite a lot of
redistribution in the system i want to
come back to the wall and talk to chris
taylor
chris uh i think you have a view about
this debate that we're having
essentially about targeting or
redistribution
well i wanted to ask about the rise in
the energy price cap um
with the possible exception of the rail
network it seems that the energy sector
is the biggest single failure
of this dogmatic application of market
forces to the provision of public
services and utilities
consumers are constantly berated to seek
out these alleged better deals comparing
ludicrously complex plans and tariffs
that frankly no one understands at the
behest of what looks increasingly like
the cartel of energy providers
bill bullon
you're part of a cartel that is
essentially
robbing the people definitely not um i
absolutely want to put the mind at ease
that the energy business is not a cartel
we're all very different um and that's
the benefit of having an open market a
company like mine is you know very
focused on the prepay market sector i
think we've innovated hugely introducing
smart pre-pay you know really bringing
pre-pay into the 21st century you know i
don't think we'd have had that if we'd
have had just a you know one state or
just a cut a simple cartel of companies
so no i you know i've been in the energy
industry actually since the 80s so
you know it's it's much more efficient
now it's much more dynamic um so you
know and delivering i think for
consumers obviously what we can't do
anything about is the cost of wholesale
which is you know the big problem that
we're all dealing with at the moment all
right there's one thing i'd like to add
is that what we're missing here is that
you know there's 13 million people
employed by small businesses okay they
don't get any help all right this is the
great debate up next who or what is the
answer to the cost of living crisis we
need to get this country moving at top
speed again we're going to level up my
government will level up we are serious
about wanting to level up this is a
government in free fall
out
have a windfall tax on oil and gas
companies and cut those bills this is
the real testing point for the
government really to start delivering
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
we saw snatch squads going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover or you die
okay so that's like a wall that's the
one yes
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
[Music]
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked where we're right
well enormous explosion has just come
down i think it was a monster just
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria but across the world
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate tonight
we're asking if you can afford the cost
of living crisis
of course the reality is that we don't
have a choice prices are going up
so let's go straight to our viewers
panel
let's talk to
will leyland about how he plans to
manage this will
hey hi everybody um yeah i'm a father
too we've got another on the way um in
june um so my partner's going to be
going on a maternity leave in march so
we're going to see a drop in our income
from that but
i i do relatively okay i'm not one low
income
um
relatively speaking we're okay but in
april i've got national insurance is
going up my gas electric fixed deal is
going to come to an end i expect the
council tax might probably go up as well
um and the cost of food and petrol
recently has been going up really really
fast it's something that i've really
noticed and really
paid attention to
they're also expecting inflation to
exceed seven percent in the spring um i
also pay back student loans as well um
and i've i've thought about
reconsidering um the possibility of
buying a house in the next year or two
because i think that the bank of england
are more than likely gonna have to rise
um the base interest rates titled this
rising inflation so there's a lot
there's an awful lot going on for you
what's your question for our panel
so my question um is is there a solution
to
the cost of living crisis
okay
question for our panel
is there a solution to the cost of
living crisis
lucy
what would you advise
mr johnson and his colleagues uh step
down and let a labor government come in
it's tough okay that's not gonna i think
we should have that that's not gonna
happen that's well i'm gonna say that's
not gonna happen tomorrow
government what should any government do
about this because whatever the color of
government they're going to face the
same problem aren't they
i mean we were just talking now about
the we i mean
about the windfall tax where we you you
that the two sides and the that yeah
well you you will explain it better
but i agree
we must not lose sight of you know what
the long-term goal has got to be i
understand this next year is going to be
really tough on the whole economy but we
were talking earlier on about
you know
moving away from environmental taxes and
not concentrating on net zero we
absolutely mustn't do that
pears made the key point i think earlier
on is that the whole economy has got to
get more efficient
that's you know absolutely essential um
and
you know the point about the windfall
tax is that you know if we want an
economy if we want britain to be a place
where you know companies are going to be
come here to do business which is you
know how we grow out of this problem
okay then um we have to have a stable
fiscal regime companies have to trust
the chancellor all right justin greeting
we've well we've heard two things
tonight
just heard about the windfall attacks
earlier we heard let's go slow on net
zero have you got anything else that you
could offer
well so i think
bill's right you do ultimately need to
fix some of these long-term issues which
is why people find themselves trapped in
low-paid jobs and they're not able to
move up the ladder so part of that is
education but i think business has a big
role to play on this
a lot of the work that i'm doing is
around getting bigger businesses in
particular to really think more
strategically about how their
opportunities change lives and how they
can be more proactive in putting them
into communities that need them how they
can be more activist on genuinely making
sure that people are skilled up to get
those opportunities they're out there
especially this new economy with net
zero and green jobs we have to make sure
that they're having an impact in the
parts of the country that perhaps
haven't had as many opportunities
but i think at the end of the day it's
mad that you've got something like an
apprenticeship levy that is there to
help upskill and reskill people
and it's so tightly drawn by ministers
that half of it apparently had to be
given back to the treasury is things
like that that you could change right
now that would allow businesses to play
more of a role themselves in helping
people connect up to jobs that are
already there and it's mad that we're in
a situation where
business has a skills gap people are
desperate to earn more money and we
can't make a connection between all
right so we're hearing about net zero
we're hearing windfall tax we're hearing
businesses can do a bit more but
actually you mentioned
other parts of the country and
the phrase of our time is leveling up
and i think
vasiliki
contour
watson has a view about leveling up
good evening yes i think uh michael gore
would certainly advocate uh that this is
the solution his latest white paper on
leveling up however that does not seem
to be the the case especially in
sunderland i do feel that the government
has let sunderland down
um
with this level up agenda um
i think things are getting worse to be
honest and and i can see on on a on a
daily basis that people are losing their
jobs i know parents who are are
struggling to put food on their table
children are going to school uh without
um you know with without enough food uh
businesses are closing so really my
question would be you know why aren't
local councils investing in helping
families with living costs
when especially in sunderland uh you
know we've got uh a massive
bout of uh millions been invested in
major recreation housing entertainment
projects okay thank you vataliki lucy
beaumont
um this is an interesting point isn't it
yeah we should invest in the things that
russ league is talking about rather than
maybe big infrastructure and they are
and and the the work i've been doing in
halifax leads hulk councils are really
involved what we've got to remember is
especially since 2000 tick tick
blackpool for for instance which is
i mean what i'd like to do is if i was
in government
you would move government to blackpool
whoa and you would sort out blackpool
and then the skills that you've learned
from sorting out blackpool you then can
you can sort anywhere out it's somewhere
like that you know you've got words that
fifty percent in
child poverty fifty percent of the
children in certain wards since 2010
they've lost over eight i think it's
getting to like 900 million pounds the
local council's lost
we're still feeling the effects of
austerity right yeah and but the the
thing that people i think people are
aware but government isn't aware because
it's so unseen that going without food
okay lucy you you summoned up an
incredible image of the glitter ball in
the middle of parliament piers last
point um
[Music]
what about this leveling up thing
i mean i grew up in the north of england
so leveling up is a great idea it's
going to take a generation i always say
there's a you know ambition it's not is
sort of evenly distributed capital
opportunity isn't the government's got
two major tools to deal with this one is
quantitative easing that drives
inflation the second one is now interest
rate so we're going to see those go up
the only way out of this and you know
local authorities a point made there
it's great and you can look after the
most vulnerable but somebody somewhere
has got to pay for it it's either
taxation on a static economy with a low
growth economy for some time now it's
really about how bill's point as well is
refer back to my point is how do we as a
nation grow out of this that is the only
answer i am pretty sure i'm afraid about
that we are i'm pretty sure we're going
to come back to this but i'm afraid
that's all we have time for this evening
and it just remains for me to thank our
panelists here in the studio piers
linney justin greening bill bulham and
lucy beaumont
well of course it's you at home we're at
the center of this conversation if you'd
like to be part of the program next time
get in touch by emailing us here at the
great debate
at sky dot uk
but for now i want to thank everybody on
our wall on the viewers panel who's
contributed tonight thank you for your
usual spirited presence see you next
time and are you at home keep talking
and we'll see you again at the same time
next week for the great debate
[Applause]
[Music]
b
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you